[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 25 janvier voici le
programme direction Les Clayes-sous-Bois
ce soir dans votre 7/8 réhabilitation de
la résidence de l'arbre sobriété
énergétique fusion avec la police
municipale de plaisir quels sont les
grands projets de l'année 2023 dans la
commune nous ferons le point avec
Philippe guigaine le maire de la ville
le député renaissance de la première
circonscription des Yvelines Charles
Rodwell a été nommée rapporteur d'une
mission parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale mais alors en quoi cela
consiste concrètement l'élu doit mener
des auditions auprès des entreprises
pour faire le point sur leur exportation
et leur attractivité économique c'est
dans le cadre du Plan France 2030 il
doit rendre son rapport à la fin du mois
nous l'avons suivi durant l'une de une
visite les Champs-Élysées l'été indien
et si tu n'existais pas je parle bien
évidemment des chansons de Joe Dassin si
vous êtes un grand fan un spectacle pour
lui rendre hommage est organisé à
Montfort la Maurice ce weekend c'est au
profit des enfants de l'hôpital de
Bullion dans les Yvelines nous en
parlerons avec nos invités claire
Belledent et Evariste Burgevin restez
bien avec nous ils nous ferons une
démonstration en live et dans votre
émission comme d'habitude nous parlerons
de cinéma puisque nous sommes mercredi
et ce sera avec vous Céline Charles
bonsoir bonsoir alors quelles sont les
sorties ciné à ne pas louper cette
semaine alors au menu cette semaine un
film d'animation made in Toulouse un
candidat aux Oscars une comédie sous
fond d'inégalité sociale et une quête
initiatique en Corée du Sud et donc ce
sera enfin à démission rester avec nous
avec nous ce soir en plateau une autre
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78
réginera les bonsoir bonsoir alors c'est
un nouveau rendez-vous le mercredi vous
nous présentez une école du territoire
jusqu'à la culture des vœux sur
parcoursup et quelle école vous allez
nous présenter ce soir régime mais
effectivement ce soir je vais vous
présenter l'école 3IS donc c'est une
école de cinéma et de Dieu visuel et on
aura aussi également avec nous des
anciens élèves de l'école qui viendront
témoigner de leur parcours professionnel
donc ce sera dans quelques instants mais
avant jetons un petit coup d'œil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
matin prévoyez des averses sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 3 à Houdan et
Rambouillet et 2 à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
dans les Yvelines et le soleil devrait
faire son apparition au niveau des
températures il fera 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 5 degrés à Houdan et 4
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons encore les pôles
mais les féminines cette fois-ci le
point maintenant sur l'actualité dans
les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Grégory canal et
bonsoir alors on commence par l'image du
jour direction l'Assemblée nationale une
dizaine d'élèves du collège Charles
Péguy du Chesnay Rocancourt ont été
reçus cette semaine dans l'assemblée
depuis le début de l'année assez jeune
rencontre des personnalités politiques
après la député des Yvelines Béatrice
Piron ils ont fait la connaissance d'une
autre parlementaire du département il y
a LeBron pivée elle est depuis l'été
dernier la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale première femme de l'histoire
de France à occupé le poste au perchoir
au menu des échanges la place des femmes
dans la vie politique et les valeurs
républicaines écoutaient ses propos
recueillis par Julien Leroy
leurs questions et puis on sent que les
réponses les intéressés ça n'est pas
machinal donc ouais c'était assez de ce
sont des bons moments je retiens
beaucoup de choses dont beaucoup de
choses sur le métier de débuter sur les
valeurs
sur comment fonctionne un peu la somnie
nationale j'étais déjà stressée avec une
des alors que la alors la
président de l'Assemblée nationale
j'étais encore plus stressé donc oui
j'étais assez stressée mais c'était très
bien et la prochaine rencontre pour les
collégiens de Charles Péguy ce sera le
17 février ils vont rencontrer et Gérard
Larcher il est-il Linois et aussi
président du Sénat on poursuit avec le
chiffre du jour c'est 80 et c'est en
rapport avec l'inflation 80% le taux de
prise en charge des investissements pour
les boulangers franciliens c'est la
région Île-de-France qui débloque cette
aide pour inciter les boulangers
durement toucher par la hausse du coup
de l'énergie à investir dans la
rénovation thermique et écologique de
leurs équipements autrement dit pour un
nouveau four à pain acheté à 10000 euros
la région rembourse à hauteur et de 8000
euros par ailleurs l'Île-de-France a
adopté également le renforcement de son
chèque énergique énergétique et faits
énergétique chèque efficacité
énergétique de 5000 à 10000 euros il
permet à des entreprises de moins de 20
salariés d'être accompagnés dans leur
travaux de rénovation énergétique et
vous avez une mauvaise
nouvelle à m'ont été 13 souvenez-vous à
la mise en ligne de cette la mise en
service de cette ligne a été effective
l'été dernier entre Saint-Cyr-l'École et
Saint-Germain-en-Laye on peut relier les
deux villes en 30 minutes alors ça ça ne
bouge pas rassurez-vous mais le
prolongement de la ligne jusqu'à Poissy
HR va lui prendre du retard le début des
travaux prévus pour la fin de l'année et
repousser finalement à fin à 2024
conséquence la mise en service de ce
tronçon de 10,5 km n'est attendu au
mieux que pour la fin 2027 début 2028
quant à qui a Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
et Cergy dans le Val-d'Oise il faudra
attendre 2030 pour voir à jour donc ce
prolongement elle a raison de ce retard
c'est la réalisation d'études
environnementales complémentaires on a
toujours jusqu'au 31 janvier pour
présenter ses vœux
de Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
a présenté ses vœux c'est les siens hier
mardi c'était à la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de Guyancourt l'occasion
de faire le point sur les futurs projets
pour l'université des projets souvent
des projets de recherche et aussi sur
l'université Paris-Saclay cette grande
structure de l'enseignement supérieur
qui va regrouper à terme trois
universités quatre grandes écoles des
IUT des unités de formation et de
recherche à l'horizon 2025 l'UVSQ va
être totalement fondu dans cette grande
université Paris Saclay on écoute le
président de l'UVSQ au micro des deux
journalistes qui sont avec nous autour
de la table réginera lèche et Céline ça
et Céline Charles c'est un changement
dans la continuité on va travailler sur
les statuts les nouveaux statuts de
notre université dans le cadre de Paris
Saclay donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important parce qu'on ça va
transformer notre université et puis on
va continuer des actions de de formation
et de recherche au niveau de en
soutenant nos collègues il y en a
tellement qu'il est difficile de vous
les citer tous peut-être en formation de
dire qu'on a on est tête de pont et
porteur d'un projet des campus des
métiers des qualifications avec
plusieurs soit partenaires dont Renault
à Flins sur l'industrie circulaire et la
mobilité et puis après le Paris
Saint-Germain le camp des Loges pourrait
avoir un nouveau pensionnaire dans les
années à venir des contacts ont été
établis entre la mairie de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et le Stade
Français c'est nos confrères du Parisien
qui a révèle l'information le club de
rugby actuel le deuxième du Top 14
cherche effectivement un nouveau centre
d'entraînement le propriétaire du Stade
Français ans Peter wild et le directeur
général Thomas Lombard ce sont notamment
rendu sur place un accord doit être
encore trouvé sur le prix et de location
le camp des Loges qui continuerait donc
d'avoir un club résident puisque les
footballeurs du Paris Saint-Germain qui
s'y entraîne depuis
1975 vont quitter les lieux pour la
ville de Poissy un centre d'entraînement
flambant neuf de 74 hectares est en
cours de construction la livraison est
prévue pour 2023 2024 merci beaucoup
Grégory canalet et si vous aussi comme
d'habitude vous voyez une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 28 news
durant tout le mois de janvier TV 78
reçoit les maires de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur commune ce soir nous recevons
Philippe Guilhem bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes le maire des Clayes-sous-Bois
est également l'un des vis président de
50 ans en Yvelines alors une thématique
qui revient énormément en ce moment
c'est la sobriété énergétique comment ça
se passe dans votre commune Philippe
guygan quelles sont les actions que vous
mettez en place nous avons des actions
que nous avons débuté dès le printemps
de 2022 des actions qui se sont traduits
par différents éléments concrets comme
des mesures de réduction de température
dans la le maximum de bâtiments de notre
de notre commune néanmoins nous avions
des marges de manœuvre peu élevées parce
que nous avions déjà anticipé ces
réductions de température pour faire des
économies sur les années en intérieur
nous avons essayé de de déjà d'anticiper
un certain nombre de possibilités par
exemple sur les panneaux solaires de
voir nous avons contacté des sociétés
pour voir si nous pouvions mettre à
disposition des bâtiments de la ville
pour pouvoir avoir de de l'énergie nous
avons pris des mesures comme beaucoup de
nos collègues comme tout nos collègues
de 51 en Yvelines sur la réduction des
horaires d'éclairage la nuit par exemple
aux Clayes-sous-Bois ça sera de 1h30 à
14h30 de manière à être homogène avec
les lignes de bus qui parcourt qui
parcourent notre ville nous avons aussi
fait des travaux d'isolation déjà dans
les bâtiments de la ville des travaux
d'isolation que nous avons pu faire
conformément à nos budgets nous avons
priorisé sur certains grands projets
comme la réhabilitation d'une école les
travaux des isolation dès le premier
exercice de travaux de manière à essayer
permet de réduire au maximum toutes ces
toute cette facture énergétique et cela
se traduit donc par une première réunion
publique à la fin du mois de novembre
avec notre population et un plan
énergétique qui va se décliner sur les
différentes allées parce que nous allons
prendre des mesures au fil de l'eau une
autre réunion est prévue avec les
habitants une autre réunion sera prévue
à la fin de ce trimestre ou au début du
prochain trimestre et quels sont les
propositions justement des habitants sur
ce sur ce sujet là les habitants pour
l'instant ils ont fait un constat avec
nous nous leur avons dit que nous avions
anticipé nous les avons mis devant les
différentes possibilités sachant que ces
différentes possibilités ne peuvent pas
se réaliser en un mois deux mois ou même
six mois il faut faire des études
préalables par exemple la géothermie la
géothermie qui peut être anticipée sur
le territoire de 50 ans c'est pour cela
que nous allons nous associer bien
entendu à l'étude de notre de notre
agglomération les panneaux solaires que
j'ai cité la valeur tout ça nécessite
des études pour pouvoir si il y a un
minimum de rentabilité par rapport à
l'investissement et puis après il y a
des mesures concrètes comme je vous ai
cité les réductions de température la
priorisation sur un certain nombre de
travaux dans le budget 2023 que nous
allons voter de manière à essayer de
limiter au maximum cette facture
énergétique on en parle de plus en plus
de cette thématique avec le contexte
environnemental mais aussi la hausse des
prix de l'énergie c'est une thématique
qui inquiète les siennes et les
chrétiens aussi les commerçants qui sont
présents dans votre ville alors c'est
une thématique qui inquiète tout le
monde depuis la commune jusqu'au
jusqu'aux habitants j'ai personnellement
discuté avec ma boulangère qui elle
avait la chance entre guillemets d'avoir
un contrat qui augmentait de plusieurs
dizaines de % ce qui est déjà énorme
mais qui n'étaient pas multiplié par 5
ou par 10 comme l'ont comment certains
donc cela inquiète tout le monde bien
entendu donc justement est-ce que vous
allez organiser aussi une réunion avec
les gros consommateurs les bailleurs les
commerçants ce qui vraiment consomment
énormément d'énergie alors cette réunion
aujourd'hui n'est pas prévue en tant que
en tant que réunion par contre nous
incitons bien entendu les bailleurs à
essayer de d'optimiser toutes ces toutes
ces factures énergétiques les
commerçants avec ma délégué au Commerce
dans la commune nous prenions des
informations mais une réunion factuelle
en tant que telle à ce jour n'est pas
prévu mais sera néanmoins programmé
lorsque nous aurons des informations
concrètes sur ce qui attend au niveau
des commerçants puisque les commerçants
comme nous-mêmes dans les communes nous
avons pas aujourd'hui encore de
situations très très claires sur ce que
nous allons payer dans les mois ou dans
les semestre à venir alors sur un autre
sujet Philippe Guyenne vous avez été
reçu en septembre dernier à Bercy pour
évoquer la dégradation de la situation
économique dans les communes où on est
ce dossier vous aviez fait plusieurs
demandes où est-ce que ça en est alors
en fait cette visite à Bercy pour moi a
permis de vraiment remonter le
mécontentement d'un certain nombre de
communes moyennes comme la mienne celle
des Clayes-sous-Bois ce sont des
communes ou finalement nous avons en
général quasiment pas d'aide et où nous
devons en général également contribuer à
quasiment tout donc il était important
que l'on remonte les difficultés de ces
communes comme la nôtre que ça soit pour
la partie énergétique que ça soit sur
les sur les aides en général alors pour
moi cette démarche a permis déjà de
remonter la situation des élus de
terrain avec leur commune et je pense
que dans un premier temps nous avons
déjà été écoutés est-ce que nous allons
être entendu nous le verrons s'il y a
des mesures très concrètes qui nous sont
retournés dans les semaines ou les mois
à venir pour l'instant pas de retour
pour l'instant pas de retour concret si
ce n'est que nous avons quand même fait
passer le message et nous attendons
trouble véritable concret sur les
factures énergétiques au niveau
électricité et au niveau gaz je dois
dire que je suis en train de bâtir notre
budget aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
encore les chiffres définitifs mais nous
avons l'impression que par rapport à ce
que nous craignons de hausse un moment
donné nous avons de très très fortes
hausses mais disons pour parler
trivialement un peu moins pire vous êtes
inquiet justement sur ce sujet là
concernant les finances dans votre
commune on peut être inquiet dans la
mesure où une commune comme la mienne ou
en tant que ancien adjoint aux finances
cela fait 12 ans que j'avais gelé les
taux communaux donc cela fait 12 ans
nous essayons de faire un maximum
d'économies dans tous les domaines quand
l'on voit une facture énergétique qui
explose comme comme cela explose dans
différentes communes pour une pour une
ville comme Les Clayes-sous-Bois
aujourd'hui la simulation d'augmentation
du gaz et d'électricité même s'il n'est
pas encore totalement définitive elle va
se situer entre 900 euros et un million
d'euros nous devons faire face aussi à
toute l'inflation
généralisée nous avons eu l'an dernier
l'augmentation du point d'indice et je
m'en félicite pour tous les tous les
collaborateurs de la ville mais tout ça
fait une somme financière qui
effectivement ne peut que nous inquiéter
alors concernant la sécurité la police
municipale des Clayes-sous-Bois va
bientôt fusionner avec celle de plaisir
alors c'était une urgence contenue d'une
pénurie d'agent dans la ville alors
c'était une urgence mais une urgence
raisonnée que nous avions anticipé avec
ma collègue de plaisir puisque nous
avons la même vision sur la sur la sur
la police c'est-à-dire une police de
prévention et de proximité la ville de
Plaisir dispose disposait aux dispose
toujours aujourd'hui d'une police avec
un nombre d'agents conséquent aux
Clayes-sous-Bois nous avions un nombre
limité d'achats et nous voyons bien que
pour conserver ces agents et avoir une
police efficace et augmenter le service
vis-à-vis de la population c'était très
très difficile d'où la nécessité de
mettre en commun des moyens humains des
moyens financiers pour améliorer notre
efficacité nous avons cependant au
niveau de la commune des
Clayes-sous-Bois un important système de
vidéo surveillance puisque nous avons
déjà plus de 140 caméras et dans la
mesure où nous avions la même vision
avec le maire de plaisir nous ne
pouvions aller que dans son sens
néanmoins même si la police municipale
est plus importante à l'heure actuelle à
plaisir nous aurons un poste aussi aux
classes sous bois comment vous expliquer
cette difficulté à recruter dans la
ville des Clayes-sous-Bois je pense que
ce n'est pas que la ville Les
Clayes-sous-Bois je pense que les
policiers municipaux ils sont attirés
par des projets dans des villes
importants avec des moyens importants et
des offres de services importants il y a
une très forte intégration des
territoires entre les clés et plaisir
donc c'était aussi tout à fait logique
d'aller dans cette voie on va parler
urbanisme à présent un des grands
projets pour la ville c'est la
réhabilitation et la modernisation des
résidences de l'oeuvre alors où est-ce
que où est-ce qu'en sont les travaux
alors déjà pourquoi pourquoi cette cette
rénovation cette résidence de lavre est
à peu près 400 logements et à peu près
50 ans nous ne sommes pas dans la ville
des Clayes-sous-Bois dans ce qu'on
appelle un quartier politique de la
ville donc nous n'avons pas d'aide
spécifique qui permettent de rénover ces
quartiers il était donc important pour
nous sur une résidence vieillissante
comme ça de trouver un accord avec le
bailleur Logirep pour rénover la
totalité de cette résidence c'est ce qui
va être le cas avec une rénovation
extérieure intérieure tous les expats
extérieurs également qui va s'étaler
entre 2021 et 2027 avec la la
suppression de deux tours mais la
requalification et le réaménagement de
nouveau le bâtiment beaucoup plus petit
ce qui va permettre également d'avoir
une mixité sociale plus importante
puisqu'il va y avoir une accession à la
propriété également sur ce quartier donc
ça va être une réhabilitation à la fois
pour cette résidence mais pour
l'ensemble du quartier vous avez dit 400
logements ça concerne combien de
familles environ alors
400 logements vous avez au moins 400
familles
si vous voulez quelques chiffres en
finale il n'y aura que 35 suppressions
de logement mais c'est logement seront
réattribués au niveau de la ville il y a
déjà un travail très important qui a
fait par le bailleur puisque toutes les
familles ont été reçues ont exprimé leur
souhait de relogement sur la commune ou
pas sur la commune mais la quasi
intégralité c'est sur la commune dans ce
quartier là dans d'autres quartiers
voilà c'est un travail de fourmi qui est
planifié et qui pour l'instant avance de
façon très très très bonne
au niveau santé une maison
pluridisciplinaire devrait voir le jour
en 2023
elle va les premiers travaux pour
débuter en 2023 j'aimerais bien qu'elle
voit le jour en 2023 mais elle verra le
jour que fin 2024 pourquoi fin
uniquement fin 2024 nous partons d'un
bâtiment qui était existant qui est
l'ancienne sécurité sociale des classes
sous bois que nous allons totalement
réaménager nous avons trois plateaux à
l'heure actuelle de 300 mètres carrés
nous allons même créer un quatrième un
quatrième plateau puisque dans le projet
global de santé nous avons un pôle un
pôle d'imagerie qui est prévu pourquoi
ce elle est aussi vite sur cette maison
de santé c'était un des projets phares
que j'avais de mon de mon mandat
constatant la difficulté au niveau du
personnel médical et paramédical de
notre commune c'est pour ça que nous
avons débuté dès l'année 2020 a
rencontré les différents partenaires
comme la RS que nous avons créé un une
association avec nos médecins pour créer
le plan de santé et que nous sommes à
l'heure actuelle dans dans la phase où
nous allons retenir un architecte pour
réaménager cette cette maison plus récit
plus riche disciplinaire de santé
sachant que nous sommes classifiés dans
une ce qu'on appelle en terme technique
en zone zip c'est-à-dire une zone très
très déficitaire en médecin vous avez
déjà des professionnels de santé à
mettre dedans nous avons déjà tout à
fait nous avons déjà puisque nous avons
créé une association et dans cette
association parce que le plan le plan de
santé se sont pas les élus qui doivent
qui doivent le mettre en place ils
doivent ils doivent venir de la part des
médicaments et des paramédicaux et donc
au fur et à mesure que le projet avance
et il avance très très bien aujourd'hui
nous avons de nouveau professionnel qui
viennent se greffer et c'est pour ça que
le plan de santé lui-même ça y est il
est déjà établi il va être déposé il a
été déposé à la RS et nous allons passer
à l'étape suivante et donc ce sont des
nouveau médecin qui vient de s'installer
ou des nouveaux pour l'instant des
médecins qui sont de la commune il y a
des paramédicaux parce que nous manquons
de pas de paramédicaux il n'a pas que le
médecin généraliste il y a aussi les
paramédicaux par exemple au
clair-sous-bois nous n'avions pu
quinquiner nous avons deux nouveaux kiné
qui sont qui sont partants pour ces pour
cette maison et nous avons aussi parmi
les médecins actuels des médecins qui se
proposent pour être des formateurs de
nouveaux médecins et qui donc viendront
éventuellement dans cette maison de
santé tout ça est un aussi un travail de
longue haleine et alors parmi les
nouveaux équipements une résidence pour
seniors devraient également voir le jour
à proximité du centre-ville tout à fait
une résidence pour Seigneur qui est très
attendue et je dois dire que Ben nous
sommes satisfaits d'avoir enfin pu
débloquer ce projet puisque il était
bloqué depuis plusieurs années mais à
l'heure actuelle le les terrains a été
vendu les anciens le bâtiment qui était
sur ces terrains sont en cours de de
destruction le projet le permis de
construire a été accepté et purgé de
tout recours et nous allons avoir la
première pierre des ce premier semestre
avec un objectif de réalisation de cette
maison pour fin de fin 2024 mais je
pense beaucoup plus raisonnablement
premier semestre 2025 sachant que nous
avons aussi négocié le fait que le
premier tour d'attribution sera aussi
revue pour les clésiens puisque il y
aura dans cette maison 20%
d'appartements qui seront à caractère
social et enfin nous avons aussi négocié
le fait que bien que nous soyons en
centre-ville donc très près du parc de
Diane très près de la forêt la
rétrocession de 700 mètres carrés qui
sera en aménagement paysager et donc
pour terminer cette entretien Philippe
guigan c'est l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe cinq questions courtes
5 réponses assez courtes vous pourrez
répondre de soi par oui ou par non soit
pour ou contre je vous laisse 20
secondes à peu près si vous voulez
donner des éléments de réponse est-ce
que vous êtes prêts je suis prêt
augmentez-vous les impôts locaux dans
votre commune en 2023 du coup ça serait
pour la première fois en 13 ans en 13
ans oui
nous sommes en train de finaliser le
budget cela ne va pas vous surprendre si
je ne peux pas vous donner de réponse à
l'heure actuelle est-ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre la circulation des 30
km/h dans la ville je suis pour une
circulation mais pour une circulation en
fonction des quartiers parce que je
considère qu'il n'y a pas la même
dangerosité dans tous les quartiers et
il faut spécifier cette zone à 30 voire
à 20 sur les quartiers qui sont les plus
accidentogènes est-ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre l'obligation de la cantine bio
dans les villes
je suis pour dans la mesure où on en
donne les moyens aux collectivités un
exercice de vos fonctions est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu peur physiquement
physiquement non je n'ai je n'ai pas eu
peur faut pas préjugés de l'avenir mais
c'est peut-être aussi parce que je
pensais être une personne de dialogue et
je suis à l'écoute des gens et on
n'hésite pas à venir me poser des
questions et enfin pour terminer est-ce
que vous êtes un maire heureux très
heureux malgré malgré les difficultés on
a de super projets à développer sur
notre ville j'ai une équipe qui est
extra donc je suis très heureux pour les
trois ou quatre ans qui restent et bien
merci beaucoup Philippe Viguen d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes le maire des
Clayes-sous-Bois c'est moi qui vous
remercie on va parler emploi maintenant
et plus particulièrement d'insertion la
septième édition de la job Academy au
château de Versailles a été lancé
vendredi dernier le principe des
employés de l'établissement accompagne
et conseils des personnes en recherche
d'emploi pendant plusieurs mois Ludivine
canard a assisté à cette première
rencontre regardée
les débuts sont timides d'un côté de la
pièce 10 filleuls en recherche d'emploi
de la Fondation agir contre l'exclusion
Yvelines et de l'autre dit par un
professionnel du château de Versailles
avec des domaines de compétences variés
par des jardins e-commerce maîtrise
d'ouvrage public accueille ou encore
surveillance après une photo souvenir la
septième édition de la job Academy est
officiellement lancée l'objectif que
l'on a à face c'est de faire en sorte
que nos bénéficiaires retrouvent en
quelques mois une nouvelle façon de
retrouver un travail de faire en sorte
que ils aient un projet professionnel
pérenne durant trois mois les binômes de
la promotion Blaise Pascal se
retrouveront tous les 15 jours pour des
rendez-vous individuels avec un diplôme
de sciences de l'éducation Jérémie
espère devenir professeur des écoles en
primaire non la recherche d'emploi on se
retrouve assez seul finalement quoi que
ce soit pour rechercher des métiers ou
ce genre de choses et avoir quelqu'un
qui aurait conversé échangé sur
différents aspects de la recherche ça
peut être très intéressant et
enrichissant en tout cas Rémi et son
par un deuxième fois
la nuit une personne en recherche
d'emploi et lui aussi il trouve son
intérêt pour moi c'est un enrichissement
personnel une activité humaine aussi
puisqu'on va découvrir quelqu'un qu'on
ne connaît pas et on va mettre tous les
moyens du château de Versailles pour
essayer de développer des gens un projet
qui peut-être est déjà très mûri à ce
que je vois déjà on a fait un petit peu
connaissance et on va essayer de faire
ensemble que ça que ça marche en fait
les binômes participeront aussi à 8
ateliers collectifs comme les clés pour
convaincre les recruteurs ou encore
l'importance des réseaux sociaux et des
réseaux professionnels on continue parce
que d'abord ça marche c'est d'une
efficacité redoutable puisque 70% des
filleuls qui sont rentrés dans ce
dispositif on trouvait un emploi à
l'issue de leur parcours et puis au-delà
de l'efficacité c'est une rencontre
humaine de très grande qualité et depuis
son lancement en 2016 une centaine de
personnes ont été accompagnées par la
job Academy
c'est un nouveau rendez-vous chaque
mercredi nous partons à la découverte
d'une école dans les Yvelines avec vous
régénéralèches vous allez nous parler de
trois is ce soir oui mais juste avant ça
j'aimerais vous poser une question
savez-vous ce que signifie l'acronyme 3e
attention faut pas répondre alors juste
pour repréciser on a accueilli deux
anciens étudiants de troisis bonsoir
avec nous du coup Hélène Le Floch et
Léonard Annette bonsoir donc troisième
je laisse les autres répondre parce que
moi j'ai la réponse
institut internationale de l'image et du
son parfait donc c'est vraiment les
trois i merci mais il faut aussi
préciser que madame est une ancienne
étudiante de 3e effectivement alors du
coup donc c'était colle elle a été créée
il y a 35 ans et on y apprend les
métiers du cinéma et de l'audiovisuel
plusieurs filières sont proposées on a
de l'acting du spectacle vivant des
effets spéciaux mais aussi des jeux
vidéo troisième c'est aussi quatre
campus en France et qui ont fait
d'ailleurs le premier campus audiovisuel
d'Europe elle présente également de très
bons chiffres puisque 84% de ses élèves
trouvent un travail moins d'un an après
la sortie de leur diplôme alors quelles
sont les frais de formation régime alors
il faut compter entre 8000 et 9000 € par
an et donc on a la chance aujourd'hui de
recevoir deux anciens élèves
effectivement donc Léonard amet et
Hélène Le Floch bonsoir encore une fois
alors je vais commencer par vous Leonard
donc vous êtes producteur réalisateur et
comédien à quoi ressemble vos journées
oulala tout ça au moins en même temps
enfin pas tous les jours tous les jours
dans la journée mais en tout cas ça
change beaucoup et c'est ça que que
j'apprécie beaucoup j'en ai même besoin
donc voilà bah ça ressemble à des
tournages ça dépend dans quel côté de la
caméra soit derrière soit devant voilà
c'est juste hyper différent et c'est
super bien voilà
je suis très content et vous du coup
Hélène qui à quoi ressemble vos journées
qu'est-ce que c'est que votre métier
puisque vous êtes régisseuse au cinéma
alors là je suis régie ce cinéma donc
sur les plateaux de fiction série cinéma
télé
et moi je m'occupe plus de la partie
logistique donc ça va être organisé tout
ce qui a créé au tournage pas du tout le
côté artistique mais plus voilà la
logistique et sur quel film est-ce que
vous avez déjà travaillé
ben écoutez j'ai travaillé sur les
tuches là j'ai un film qui sort au
cinéma le mois prochain qui va s'appeler
Néné superstar
on va en parler tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui super
et alors justement pour effectuer ces
métiers quels sont les filières qu'on
peut choisir justement dans l'école 3IS
vous êtes passés par quelle filière
exactement
alors moi j'ai fait une formation
d'assistante mise en scène script donc
pas grand chose à voir a priori avec mon
métier actuel mais ce qui est bien un
troisième c'est que la formation elle
est assez globale assez générale en
première année on touche à tout et c'est
ça que je trouve vraiment intéressant
dans cette école et vous moi du coup
j'ai fait mise en scène donc réalisation
mais mise en scène parce que moi à mon
époque alors je sais pas j'ai pas trop
envie de parler de maintenant ça va
peut-être bouger mais à mon époque on
avait deux spéc réalisations on avait
mis en scène d'un côté une spé plus télé
télévision
moi j'ai fait mise en scène donc voilà
on nous a appris le travail avec les
comédiens on a eu tout de suite ce que
j'adore avec cette école les mains sur
les caméras immédiatement et voilà moi
j'ai fait ça mise en scène et alors
comment est-ce que vous avez intégré
troisis moi personnellement ça s'est
fait je suis allé en fait
une journée portes ouvertes c'est comme
ça que j'ai découvert en fait l'école
et je l'ai intégré via à l'époque
c'était un concours après les portes
ouvertes et puis après j'ai pu faire ma
masse tranquillement
et je pense que le concours est toujours
accessible enfin c'est toujours sur
concours une partie sur parcoursup je
crois pour certaines formations et
d'autres formations par concours alors
est-ce que vous avez des conseils pour
les étudiants les lycéens qui voudraient
intégrer troisis sur sur ce concours
est-ce que vous avez des petits tips ça
leur donner des petits tips sinon je
veux dire de soi savoir ce qu'on veut
être créatif
ce truc des portes ouvertes enfin en
tout cas moi ça m'a vraiment servi puis
ça permet aussi de faire un potentiel
comparatif entre les écoles ce qui est
assez intéressant je pense d'ailleurs je
tiens juste à préciser que les
prochaines portes ouvertes sont le 18
février yes et comment pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi cette école
troisième est-ce que vous aviez vu ces
points forts quelles sont ses qualités
justement alors moi c'est vraiment
l'aspect technique est vraiment comme je
disais d'avoir la chance dès le mois je
crois que c'était incroyable dès le
deuxième jour ou même le premier jour on
a fait un truc travaux pratiques
caméra dans la main et on te dit ok fait
un panoramique enfin tu découvres c'est
les bases mais c'est pas les bases sur
papier et je crois que c'est vraiment
pour ça que j'ai été j'étais dans cette
école
c'est un peu pareil l'aspect technique
il est il est énorme on s'était école
alors je vais pas faire de mauvaises pub
aux autres écoles mais c'est vrai que le
campus à Paris est équipé de énormément
d'équipement celle de ciné motion
capture voilà ils ont un parc matériel
qui est très grand pour une école et on
a surtout ce qui est chouette dans cette
école c'est qu'on a la possibilité
d'utiliser tous ces équipements au cours
de la scolarité ce qui est pas donné à
tout le monde lors de sa scolarité
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez eu des
difficultés à la sortie de l'école je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de parents qui
ont quand même peur de ce monde du
cinéma de l'audiovisuel ce qu'il faut en
avoir peur enfin oui effectivement quel
a été votre votre expérience et quel
conseil vous pourriez donner par rapport
à cet univers alors bon je vais répondre
pour mon cas mes parents sont pas du
tout de ce milieu là ils avaient très
peur effectivement à l'approche de la
sortie de l'école et contre toute
attente ça c'est très bien passé pour
moi j'ai un souvenais un premier stage
qui s'est bien passé après en fait j'ai
eu du travail j'ai encore du travail
quoi ça marche très bien pour moi donc
effectivement la peur de parents elle
est légitime mais je pense que voilà si
on croit en son enfant avec son enfant
est motivé il y a pas de souci là-dessus
clairement
moi c'est pareil pour moi la différence
que je j'ai des parents qui sont dans le
milieu j'ai pas toujours grandi dans le
milieu du cinéma de la télé de la
publicité j'ai pas en comédien mon
majeure partie font aussi d'autres trucs
mais ils sont comédiens et du coup j'ai
pas eu ce concept enfin il m'avait quand
même prévenu parce qu'ils connaissent un
peu l'histoire donc il m'avait quand
même prévenu et c'est vrai que moi je
voulais vraiment que être comédien à la
base et c'est aussi pour pouvoir avoir
d'autres cordes à mon arc et pouvoir
m'en sortir après que j'ai fait et de la
Real et après par la force des choses un
peu de production et justement est-ce
que les professeurs vous préparent à
cette insertion professionnelle
oui bah dans le déjà dans le sens où
enfin à mon sens tu vas dire mais c'est
des gens qui sont dans le secteur qui
sont enfin dans le milieu nous les profs
qu'on a eu c'est des gens qui qui sur
des films à côté il y en a qui ont
travaillé il y en a qui travaillaient
encore sur des films donc oui oui
clairement on a une sorte de préparation
après on a peut-être pas dans ma branche
en tout cas moi je le truc que j'aurais
bien aimé avoir c'est un petit peu plus
de conscience de voilà il faut on
connaissait les bases de l'intermittence
mais connaître je sais pas on nous avait
pas trop parler des différents statuts
dans lesquels on aurait pu découler
après comment ça se passait précisément
peut-être que les producteurs ont eu
plus ça ils connaissent un petit peu
plus les papiers nous un peu moins donc
voilà c'est le seul truc que j'ai un peu
moins eu Céline vous vouliez réagir oui
vous avez dit que vous aviez touché à la
caméra dans les premiers jours est-ce
que vous avez un petit peu des exemples
de cours de projets que vous avez eu un
petit peu pour donner envie à ceux qui
voudraient rejoindre l'école au couteau
à vous donner envie
on a une caméra la première chose qu'on
nous dit c'est voilà vous avez un
matériel à 25000 € entre les mains
amusez-vous voilà donc c'est plus c'est
plutôt agréable et après très
concrètement les projets ces premières
années fin de première année en
court-métrage deuxième année une série
fiction donc en quatre épisodes et
tourner en caméra cinéma avec des vrais
caméra cinéma je veux dire ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur un long métrage actuel et
derrière année court-métrage voilà
la plupart du temps voué à être diffusé
dans des festivals donc c'est quand même
assez ça donne envie quoi et vous avez
justement à participer à des festivals
comme le Nikon Film Festival
Les Films après coup oui alors les films
qu'on fait en 3e année c'était ça la
question c'est pas trop destiné aux
Nikon parce que c'est assez court le
Nikon et les films troisième année de
mémoire c'est 15 minutes enfin après je
sais pas ce qu'il y a ça a changé
pas avec nos films de fin d'année voilà
pas avec nos films de fin d'année et
nous notre film de fin d'année n'a pas
eu la chance d'être dans beaucoup de
festival mais en fait c'est pas grave
des étudiants qui partent au Festival de
Cannes il me semble oui alors ça c'est
un partenariat avec l'école l'avantage
de l'école aussi c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de partenariats avec les
cérémonies artistiques françaises que ce
soit les Césars Cannes qu'est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres les lumières enfin il y a
beaucoup de partenariats c'est ça qui
est assez intéressant dans l'école c'est
qu'on peut vraiment toucher à tout et on
nous donne envie aussi ça c'est très
important dans la troisième
et si je peux me permettre moi j'aurai
une dernière question
quel serait votre meilleur souvenir à 3
is
partager ou chacun son chemin
mon meilleur souvenir c'est la cérémonie
des Césars je pense 2017
mais c'était de pouvoir tourner moi
j'étais en mise en scène donc j'ai pu
réaliser mon film avec une vraie équipe
caméra de cinéma et c'est une vraie
bonne carte de visite merci beaucoup
Hélène et Léonard d'être venu nous
parler de 3e votre ancienne école en
plateau et on vous souhaite plein de
belles choses pour pour votre avenir
professionnel et on le rappelle les
lycéens ont jusqu'au jeudi 9 mars pour
formuler leurs vœux sur la plateforme
parcoursup et donc je le disais en tout
début d'émission Charles Rodwell le
député de la première circonscription
des Yvelines a été nommée rapporteur
d'une mission parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale il doit mener
plusieurs auditions auprès des
entreprises pour dresser un bilan sur
leur exportation et leur attractivité
économique et début janvier il était
présent à prodways une entreprise
d'impression 3D située à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
se régénérer je vous avais pu assister à
cette visite être attentif et à l'écoute
des entreprises un impératif pour
Charles Rodwell le député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines a récemment
été nommé rapporteur d'une mission
d'information pour l'Assemblée nationale
il réalise des auditions pour améliorer
les dispositifs de soutien à l'export et
à l'attractivité économique lorsqu'une
entreprise comme produites nous dit
qu'elle a besoin de simplifier les
dispositifs qu'elle a besoin d'être
accompagné à l'export et bien
nécessairement c'est un impact direct
sur le métier de parlementaire tant
lorsqu'on bâtit et lorsqu'on vote la loi
que dans les liens qu'on peut avoir avec
les administrations de l'État pour
soutenir les entreprises pour broadways
entreprise spécialisée dans l'impression
3D et leader sur le marché européen ces
visites sont également le moment de
dresser un bilan des dispositifs et de
faire part de ses problématiques
l'intérêt il est multiple attiré
l'intention sur le fait que c'est un
marché qui est très récent qui fait
l'objet d'une concurrence internationale
qui est-ce qu'elle est par exemple les
entreprises de la 3D dans le milieu
américain sont soutenus par la bourse
avec d'élever de fonds de milliards ou
de plusieurs millions alors que la nôtre
qui date de 2017 était de 60 millions
alors que le déficit commercial a
atteint des records en 2022 la France
demeure pour la troisième fois
consécutive le pays européen le plus
attractif en termes d'investissement
étrangers l'objectif est alors de
poursuivre la dynamique engagée plus
d'une trentaine de visites sont prévues
en France le député a jusqu'à la fin du
mois de janvier pour dresser un bilan
alors est-ce que vous êtes fan de Joe
Dassin en plateau Céline Grégory c'est
pas le mot mais on connaît beaucoup de
chansons
forcément moi il y a l'été indien tout
de suite le côté romantique c'est qui
qui parle mais l'été indien en plus
cette semaine on a on avait appris une
petite anecdote sur les Indiens comme
quoi ça avait été on avait changé un peu
les notes pour en faire destiner après
donc il y a des liens avec tout mais oui
les Champs-Élysées aussi
qui nous a chanté toutes les chansons
tout à l'heure par cœur vraiment
passionné peut-être qu'il va passer je
sais pas avant la fin de l'émission mais
on a un passionné de Joe Dassin chez
Nicolas dandry aujourd'hui en tout cas
sachez que samedi prochain l'association
Paris musique et le Lion's Club de
Montfort la Maury organise un spectacle
cabaret en hommage à Joe Dassin c'est au
profit des enfants malades et porteurs
de handicap de de l'hôpital de Bullion
dans les Yvelines et pour en parler avec
nous du coup claire Belledent et
Evariste Burgevin bonsoir bonsoir alors
Evariste Burgevin vous êtes guitariste
et Claire Belledent vous êtes chanteuse
mais avant de parler de ce spectacle
cabaret est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter ce qu'est l'association Paris
musique alors Paris musique c'est un
ensemble de musiciens de chanteurs de
comédiens aussi nous sommes amis et nous
nous sommes regroupés autour d'un projet
hommage à Joe Dassin qui a vu le jour il
y a déjà plusieurs années en fait moi
j'ai pris des cours de musique avec un
ancien compositeur de Joe Dassin et en
fait je me suis dit mais il faudra
absolument faire un hommage à Joe Dassin
donc je lui ai soufflé l'idée j'en ai
parlé également à un de mes amis qui est
chorégraphe et en fait tous les trois on
a monté un hommage à Joe Dassin donc on
a on a produit ce spectacle à la
lanterne à Rambouillet en 2018 et puis
en fait après
Christophe est parti en Belgique
Vivien Valais donc compositeur des yeux
d'Émilie pour Joe Dassin
voulait sortir du projet parce qu'en
fait il est compositeurs il voulait
s'occuper de ses chansons et donc autour
de moi j'avais des amis artistes et donc
j'ai proposé à Evariste donc guitariste
compositeur voilà j'ai proposé à
François qui fait du théâtre avec nous
et qui est guitariste également à
Sylvain qui est comédien un Marisa qui
est une amie chanteuse et à Serge qui
fait du théâtre et qui chante aussi très
bien donc vous êtes une petite troupe
d'amis comédien musicien chanteur
et du coup dans ce spectacle hommage à
Joe Dassin vous faites revivre du coup
ces musiques mais avec une petite touche
d'humour je crois alors voilà en fait
on raconte
comment on arrive à telle chanson etc et
puis et puis en fait on a des petits
skate
c'est monté comme un spectacle de
cabaret donc c'est pas juste un
enchaînement de chansons il se passe des
choses et donc vous avez chanté quelle
chanson
plein de chansons très connues sifflées
sur la colline et si tu n'existais pas
sans parler tout à l'heure
la bande à Jojo
c'est quoi votre chanson préférée à vous
de Joe Dassin
il y en a plein
à toi elle est très belle
c'est garou qui a repris beaucoup les
chansons de Joe Dassin Vianney également
[Musique]
c'est un peu intergénérationnel c'est ce
qu'on se disait avec Evariste parce que
les unités de kids ont repris des
chansons de Joe Dassin aussi donc voilà
ce que je disais de Joe Dassin les
musiques sont très connues les airs
encore plus ça parle à toutes les
générations vous aussi vous êtes
passionné de Joe Dassin et variste
comment vous êtes vous avez rejoint
cette aventure du coup par amitié au
début je suis pas spécialement un fan de
Joe Dassin même si je vis encore écouter
dans la voiture avec mes parents tous
les gens de mon âge et puis en fait je
me suis surpris à en connaître la
plupart des musiques et puis on fait bon
on se prononce laisse prendre au jeu
c'est sympa la musique est bien écrite
donc ça permet de se laisser un petit
peu enfin ça fait plaisir de jouer un
petit peu des morceaux comme ça il y a
pas de pression c'est agréable c'est
facile c'est
c'est sympa et c'est surtout pour des
belles œuvres donc en fait ça permet de
justement de
réunir du monde sous avec des arguments
et votre morceau préféré à toi aussi à
toi vous êtes raccord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire une petite
démonstration en live oui sur et ben
allez-y je vous en prie quand vous a
préparé sur le petit second plateau vous
avez vos instruments c'est une première
dans le 7 8 une démonstration live on
avait déjà eu le rappeur curta qui avait
fait un petit rap en live donc sans
instrument sans accompagnement là c'est
une première pour pour le 7 8
quand vous êtes prêt vous pouvez y aller
[Musique]
sur l'avenue le cœur ouvert à l'inconnu
j'avais envie de dire bonjour à
n'importe qui
n'importe qui et ce fut toi je t'ai dit
n'importe quoi suffisait de te parler
pour t'apprivoiser
aux Champs-Élysées
au soleil sous la pluie à midi ou à
minuit il y a tout ce que vous voulez
Champs-Élysées tu m'as dit j'ai
rendez-vous dans un sous-sol avec des
fous qui vivent la guitare à la main du
soir au matin alors je t'ai accomp on a
chanté on a lancé et on a même pas pensé
à s'embrasser
aux Champs-Élysées
au soleil sous la pluie à midi ou à
minuit à tout ce que vous voulez chanter
les
concept démonstration je vous laisse
revenir tranquillement en plateau et
alors ça nécessite combien d'années de
travail pour pouvoir chanter comme ça ou
jouer cette chanson ça demande beaucoup
de travail ça demande quand même pas mal
de répétitions de la régularité surtout
après avec n'importe quel activité quoi
que ce soit un instrument ou même la
voix ça donne comme un investissement
qui prend quand même pas mal d'années
donc c'est mon investissement voilà puis
après par contre c'est pas très
compliqué une fois qu'on y est
c'est fluide voilà mais bon on rajoute
des petites choses et c'est vrai que le
spectacle entre le premier spectacle de
2018 et ce qu'on fait maintenant ça n'a
plus rien à voir parce qu'en fait il y a
même d'autres chansons d'autres artistes
qu'on a inclus dans ce spectacle et puis
effectivement des petits skates avec
Sylvain donc ça donne une autre
dimension et
en général les gens sont très contents
on fait danser les gens
ça va chanter
on est en train de chanter de danser
déjà mais ça parle tout de suite on
reconnaît l'air et donc on me disait
c'est une soirée au profit des enfants
malades de l'hôpital pédiatrique de
Bullion c'était quelque chose qui vous
tenait à corps à cœur c'était important
pour c'est-à-dire que quand on nous a
parlé de de ce projet bien sûr on est
toujours sensible quand on nous parle
des enfants malades et
[Musique]
Truman Show sorti en 1998 par peterware
nous sommes ici sur une réalisation très
poussée très pointue et très calculé
avec à la musique Philippe Blas un
compositeur de musique classique qui
apporte ce film un véritable enfermement
et une recherche justement de liberté
nous avons comme acteur principal Jim
Carrey qui va faire face à un scénario
de Andrew Nicole très très poussé donc
Truman Show le show de Truman c'est un
de la télé-réalité de Truman Truman donc
interprété par Jim Carrey est un acteur
qui va être depuis sa naissance
entièrement filmée par des caméras il ne
le sait pas c'est un enfant c'est un
bébé il aura une caméra juste au-dessus
de sa tête au dessus de nous de son
landau au début du film et on va avoir
cet enfant fait grandir dans sa vraie
vie tous les gens qui l'entourent bien
évidemment ce comme il y a des acteurs
qui vont évoluer avec lui au fur et à
mesure des années et les spectateurs
auront un regard complètement différent
et extérieur à la situation tout ça nous
amène en fait sur un jean Carrey qui est
dans un élément complètement différent
de son humour de ses expressions folles
de ces grimaces on est sur quelqu'un de
calme de plus sérieux de plus posé on va
parler vraiment d'un drame je pense
social
[Musique]
se filmer touchant et mouvant même
extraordinairement
humain on peut parler d'une ode à la
liberté individuelle une critique de la
téléréalité et de la société
[Musique]
vous l'avez vu ce film Céline Grégory
show c'est que aujourd'hui encore il est
d'actualité parce que c'est une critique
un peu de la télé-réalité et Jim Carrey
dans ce rôle
et vraiment top et en plus voilà bon
c'est vrai que Jimmy moi j'adore ce côté
où il joue avec son visage ses
expressions c'est beaucoup du comique de
situation et il est très très bon dans
ce rôle là on poursuit cette page cinéma
avec vous Céline Charles on fait le
point sur les sorties ciné de cette
semaine le premier film que vous nous
proposez c'est Néné super star on en
parlait tout à l'heure oui on en parlait
tout à l'heure on commence donc par une
comédie dramatique réalisée par Ramzi
Benslimane nen est une petite fille
noire de 12 ans née pour danser elle
vient d'intégrer l'école de ballet de
l'Opéra de Paris mais va devoir faire
face à de nombreux obstacles dans son
ascension elle va être confrontée aux
discriminations et préjugés des sons
d'entrée à l'école surtout de la part de
la directrice de l'établissement qui est
incarné par l'actrice et réalisatrice
Maïwenn un film qui dénonce le raciste
systémique dans la danse classique mais
qui s'adresse aussi à tous les jeunes
avec des rêves regarder
[Musique]
vous êtes le directeur de l'opéra mais
je suis la directrice de l'école de
danse
use c'est pas un métier c'est une chance
pour elle il faut de la persévérance de
la santé et de la chance
toi tourne
tourne tu arrives pas romane voilà
si tu continues à poser autant de
problèmes tu ne vas pas faire long feu
chez nous et cette semaine les plus
jeunes et les moins jeunes aussi
d'ailleurs pourront partir à la
rencontre de Patti oui Mathilde avec
pati la colère de Poséidon de David halo
c'est un superbe film d'animation
français à découvrir avec toute la
famille dans ce film direction la Grèce
antique qu'on va suivre les aventures
d'une souris aventurière justement d'un
chat qui l'a adopté de ses amis tous
plus loufoque les uns que les autres
leur mission sauver la population qui
est menacée par la colère de Poséidon
l'opération les mènera affronter les
créatures mythiques les plus dangereuses
de la mythologie regardez un extrait je
vous laisse 7 jours pour me faire une
statue aussi belle que celle de mon
frère allez fillette tout le monde
compte sur nous
c'est parti
ça va ça pas vraiment on a aucune idée
qu'on va rencontrer t'inquiète pas on
est quand même avec le plus grand héros
de la Grèce à la traque
ça fait de traverser ce genre de gros
temps sur un bateau
mais j'arrive
rajoute des éclairs
et vous nous proposez un autre film
Céline Charles c'est retour assez où
exactement un film de Dave vishu retour
à Séoul nous parle de Freddy une jeune
femme de 25 ans née en Corée du Sud mais
adopté en France à l'âge d'un an elle va
se retrouver dans son pays de naissance
sur un coup de tête et va entreprendre
de retrouver sa famille biologique dont
elle ignore tout alors ce n'est pas un
film classique sur l'adoption le
réalisateur en tant qu'asser les clichés
sur le sujet c'est un film sur la quête
de soi avec un personnage captivant et
moderne alors on passe maintenant au
drame de la semaine il s'agit de tard du
cinéasta de field c'est un thriller
psychologique contemporain avec la
superbe quête Blanchette en vedette
alors tare est une chef d'orchestre
charismatique est plutôt maniaque du
contrôle elle est au sommet de sa gloire
et de son art elle attend même le
lancement de son livre et prépare un
concerto très attendu lorsqu'elle se
voit accusée de harcèlement sexuel et
moral s'en suit alors une intéressante
aux enfers pour la virtuose c'est un
film sur les rapports de pouvoir la
cancel culture et les réseaux sociaux on
peut un peu dire que c'est le film phare
de la semaine il est très attendu par
les spectateurs quatre Blanchettes et
d'ailleurs nominés à l'Oscar de la
meilleure actrice merci beaucoup c'est
en parlant de nomination les nominations
pour les Césars 2023 ont été annoncées
exactement alors c'est le rendez-vous
encore incontournable du 7e art les
Césars récompenses chaque année la crème
du cinéma français parmi les nominés on
retrouve cette année deux yvelinois
première mangeant du jardin dans la
catégorie Meilleure acteur pour son rôle
dans le film novembre sortie en octobre
dernier il interprète un policier de la
sous-direction antiterroriste qui mène
une enquête policière suivant les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 l'acteur
qui a grandi à plaisir a déjà été
récompensé trois fois trois fois lors
des Césars dans la catégorie meilleur
acteur dans OSS 117 en 2007 The Artist
en 2012 et j'accuse en 2020 on retrouve
aussi Nadia terrestrevitch dans la
catégorie Meilleur espoir féminin pour
son rôle dans le film Les Amandiers
sortis en novembre dernier elle y
incarne une jeune étudiante à l'école du
Théâtre des Amandiers de Nanterre
l'actrice qui est née à Versailles avait
déjà été présélectionné au César en 2020
pour le meilleur espoir féminin mais ce
prix si elle le remporte sera le premier
en tout cas pour les deux acteurs et
réponse le 24 février prochain lors de
la cérémonie et bien suivra ça avec
impatience merci beaucoup Céline Charles
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
regardons la météo de demain
demain matin prévoyez des averses sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 3 à Houdan et
Rambouillet et 2 à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
dans les Yvelines et le soleil devrait
faire son apparition au niveau des
températures il fera à 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 5 degrés à ou dans et 4
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]